how does it feel to come to this 2012 as
YouTube the Royal
I mean you just say this kid came up and
gave me a hug it's like it's like that
non-stop it's like people just give me
love it's like you know it's everywhere
I go as people just are I love it on me
and it's like they're acknowledging me
and it's interesting it's interesting
because I never wanted or cared about it
or tried you know it just happened and
it's like and it's personified in the
fact that you don't see me in my video I
mean but yeah I'm so recognizable it's
it's all interesting stuff and I you
know it makes me think and I and I it
blows me away
I didn't want this or care about it and
yet here it is and it goes to the fact
that I made myself the best myself an
effective vessel universe and a servant
servant for my fellow man and because i
did that powerful things happen well and
what instance powerful things have
happened I'm sure
amount of opportunities
awkward oh the boot remember we're
talking about the movie yeah they just
told me that it's happening there like
I'm going to comic-con and I'm going to
do some promotion for it so like I was
surprised i thought it got to a point
where it's like oh that's not going to
happen and then I hear like the Bliss
publicist is calling me and saying okay
this is going on this is what you need
to say it's like so so what's going on
is they're going to make it into a
feature-length blockbuster movie with
like big stars yeah so like they said
you can't say who is going to be but but
but yeah we have you know we've got been
green-lighted and it's a go and we're
going to start the capacity on it that's
interesting because it should be fun i
mean i got to hang out with fellow
youtubers and it was a you know fun
doing all the work and you know being on
saying all that it's all it's all about
no we did the trip when we did the
trailer it was a low budget thing I mean
so but I imagine I've been on some
shoots and it's like yeah that's what
it's like you know it's really fun got
someone taking care of you the whole
time of pathway it's like wow really I'm
just like this poor farmer yeah it's fun
stuff
you